we've got breaking news overnight from
the Boy Scouts of America one of the
most cherished institutions of the 20th
century is now struggling to survive the
organization which has about 2.2 million
youth members and 800,000 volunteers is
filing for federal bankruptcy protection
to prepare for a potential avalanche of
sexual abuse cases tens of millions of
other Americans have been part of
scouting over the past 110 years
Errol Barnett has been covering the
story and spoke to a former scout who
says he was abused or what is his
bankruptcy filing all about this is very
very unnerving to hear this about the
boy certainly certainly good morning
good morning team well in an email sent
out to members Boy Scout leaders said
scouting programs will continue but they
plan to use the chapter 11 filing to
restructure now and compensate victims
and consider this nearly eight thousand
Boy Scout leaders have been accused of
sex abuse Ralph Moss says he's one of
those victims he never reported the
alleged abuse he suffered at the hands
of his Boy Scout leader but claims
people knew about it when you close your
eyes are still there it'll never go away
Ralph Moss was 11 years old when he says
Boy Scout leader John Brown began
molesting him in rural upstate New York
what was some of your first memories of
John Brown
John Brown was an extremely large man
six-foot 3 4 260 pounds
you always put three of us in the front
seat of the car and for pizza and soda
and back those days the stick shift is
on the column so when you're shifting
gears his hand would drop into your lap
now this guy's hand was as big as my
head so what am I supposed to do jump
out of the car
scream run I mean he was terrifying Moss
now 67 says his older brother Harvey
also endured Browns abuse prompting both
boys to drink ended up dropping out of
high school I ended up going down a
spiral in a dark place for 25 years
my brother didn't make it he died at a
relatively young age so my alcoholism
because of the abuse in a statement the
Boy Scouts of America tells CBS News
they barred Braun from the organization
when they learned about his actions from
law enforcement and in an email sent
overnight the Boy Scouts acknowledged
systemic failures in protecting their
members from abuse while pointing out
prevention measures it claims have
dramatically reduced those cases in
recent years what does a bankruptcy
filing by the Boy Scouts mean to you
it's an admission of guilt
by filing bankruptcy you're admitting
that in all probability you're going to
be liable for these victims these
documented victims and it's going to
cost you a great deal of money
now most claims his abuse ended when he
stopped showing up to the Boy Scouts but
he believes Brown continued to molest
other kids for years Brown was arrested
in the mid-1980s and pleaded guilty to
assaulting a minor and according to a
public record he died back in 1987
well 97 excuse me but as mr. Morris
points out even if the abuse ended when
he left the scouts the effects of it
lingered for us we see that it is that
experience is still with him and he says
that if he spiraled out of control he
wants the Boy Scouts to do more to
protect young boys and even the
organization that national chairman
acknowledges that measures
enough to protect children and he says
he's sorry but all these years later you
can still feel his pain is palpable and
that's why he's speaking at one of
thousands of alleged cases precisely
perils thank you